♪ ♪
>> Tucker: RECENTLY IT WAS
CONSIDERED TOTALLY OUT-OF-BOUNDS
TO QUESTION SOMEONE'S PATRIOTISM
BECAUSE OF POLITICAL DIFFERENCE
IN WASHINGTON.
THAT WAS CALLED McCARTHYISM.
AND ONLY THE LOWEST SORT OF
PEOPLE ENGAGED IN IT.
NOW IT IS COMPLETELY PAR FOR THE
COURSE FOR PEOPLE ON THE LEFT TO
ACCUSE YOU OF TREASON IF YOU
DARE.
CASE IN POINT, DEPTH
TULSI GABBARD, A DEMOCRAT AND
FORMER SITTING MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, CHALLENGE THE IDEA IT
WOULD BE GOOD POLICY FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO FIGHT A HOT
WAR WITH RUSSIA.
FOR SAYING THAT, BY THE WAY SHE
SPEAKS WITH THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS IN MAKING
THAT OBVIOUS POINT, BUT FOR
DOING IT, MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES CALLED HER A TRAITOR.
"TULSI GABBARD IS PARROTING
FALSE RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA," WROTE
MITT ROMNEY OF YOU CALL.
"HER TREASONOUS LIES MAKE WHILE
COST LIVES."
LUDICROUS BUT STILL ALIVE
AGREED.
HE SAID TULSI GABBARD IS A
"RUSSIAN ASSET" WHO BELONGS IN
JAIL.
NOW THIS KIND OF STUFF FLIES
AROUND THE INTERNET ALL DAY LONG
AND MOST PEOPLE KIND OF SHRUG IT
OFF AND KEEP MOVING BUT
TULSI GABBARD DOES NOT SEEM LIKE
SHE IS GOING TO.
SHE IS ON THE VERGE TONIGHT OF
TAKING LEGAL ACTION AGAINST BOTH
MITT ROMNEY AND KEITH OLBERMANN.
WE SHOULD TELL YOU, YOU PROBABLY
KNOW, KELSEY GARRETT IS A U.S.
ARMY RESERVE OFFICER ENTERING
JUST TONIGHT TO EXPLAIN HER
DECISION.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
RESPOND TO THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET ME SAY I
TOOK AN OATH, AS YOU MENTIONED,
I STILL SERVE IN THE U.S. ARMY
RESERVES, TODAY I AM A HUMAN
LIEUTENANT COLONEL AND 19 YEARS
AGO WHEN I LISTED IN THE
MILITARY I TOOK AN OATH TO
DEFEND OUR CONSTITUTION.
I TOOK THAT VERY SAME OATH WHEN
I WAS ELECTED TO SERVE IN
CONGRESS, WHERE I SERVED FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
SENATOR MITT ROMNEY HAS TAKEN
THAT OATH, AS HAS EVERY OTHER
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO HAS HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING, AND IF
MITT ROMNEY HAD READ THE
CONSTITUTION, HE WOULD KNOW THAT
TREASON COME OF A CRIME HE IS
ACCUSING ME OF THAT IS
PUNISHABLE BY DEATH IS SO
SERIOUS THAT OUR FOUNDERS
DEEMED IT TO BE THE ONLY CRIME
WORTHY OF BEING DEFINED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
AND SO THE SITUATION WE ARE
FACING HERE IS A VERY SERIOUS
ONE, NOT BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT ME,
BECAUSE IT HAS A MUCH BIGGER
IMPACT ON OUR COUNTRY.
AND POWERFUL AND INFLUENTIAL
PEOPLE BASICALLY THREATEN AND
INTIMIDATE PEOPLE INTO SILENCE,
AS MITT ROMNEY, KEITH OLBERMANN,
AND OTHERS ARE DOING, THEY ARE
HOPING TO ACHIEVE THAT EFFECT,
THAT IF ANYBODY DARES TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT, THAT
IF ANYBODY DARES TO CRITICIZE
WHATEVER THE PERMANENT
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENTS
NARRATIVE IS, THEN YOU WILL BE
SMEARED AS A TRAITOROUS,
TREASONOUS TRADER, AND FRANKLY,
IF MITT ROMNEY IS SERIOUSLY
BELIEVES I HAVE COMMITTED
TREASON, WHY HASN'T HE BROUGHT
AT ANY EVIDENCE OR BROUGHT
CHARGES, HE CLEARLY DOESN'T CARE
THERE ARE ANY CONSEQUENCES, OR
AS I MENTIONED, HE IS JUST
TRYING TO INTIMIDATE AND BULLY
ME AND OTHERS INTO COURT
SILENCE.
>> Tucker: MAY ASK A QUESTION?
MITT ROMNEY FAMOUSLY DODGED THE
WAR IN VIETNAM, HE IS A COWARD.
YOU SERVED IN THE U.S. MILITARY
AND YOU TALK TO PEOPLE WHO ALSO
SERVED AND MIGHT BE CALLED TO
FIGHT THIS WAR AGAINST RUSSIA.
PEOPLE CURRENTLY SERVING IN THE
U.S. MILITARY, HOW MANY BELIEVE
RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
A WAR WITH RUSSIA IS A GOOD IDEA
CONSTITUTES TREASON?
TO A LOT OF FELLOW OFFICERS
THINK WHAT YOU SAID IS
TREASONOUS?
>> OUT A SINGLE PERSON I KNOW,
THAT I HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING WITH, AND EVEN THOSE I
DON'T KNOW PERSONALLY, WHO TAKE
THIS OATH TO SUPPORT AND DEFEND
OUR CONSTITUTION, TO BE LOYAL TO
OUR COUNTRY, WEARING THE
UNIFORM, KNOWING WE CAN BE
CALLED TO GIVE OUR LIVES IN
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AT ANY
TIME, I AM CONFIDENT IN SAYING
THEY WOULD NOT AGREE WITH HIS
ACCUSATIONS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, I AM NOT
SURPRISED AT ALL.
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY FACE THE
RISK UNDERSTAND WE NEED THE
CONVERSATION.
SO HOW DO YOU THINK HE MIGHT
REACT TO THIS?
>> WE WILL SEE.
WE HAVE SENT THE CEASE AND
DESIST LETTERS TO SENATOR ROMNEY
AS WELL AS KEITH OLBERMANN AND
IT IS IN THE HOST THEY WILL
RECOGNIZE, GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW WHAT, ON SECOND
THOUGHT, WE UNDERSTAND HOW
SERIOUS THIS CRIME OF TREASON
IS.
WE WILL APOLOGIZE AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN BECAUSE IF WE LOVE OUR
COUNTRY, WE CARE ABOUT OUR
DEMOCRACY, WE CARE ABOUT
FREE SPEECH, THE LAST THING
ANYONE WITH A PLATFORM SHOULD
WANT TO DO IS TO CREATE THIS
CHILLING EFFECT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS,
WHETHER THEY ARE MAINSTREAM OR
NOT, WHETHER THEY ARE IN LINE
WITH THOSE IN POWER IN
WASHINGTON OR NOT.
THIS IS AMERICA, AND WE ALL NEED
TO STAND UP AND PROTECT THIS
SPEECH BECAUSE TODAY IT IS ME,
TOMORROW IT COULD BE YOU.
>> Tucker: YEAH, I MEAN,
OLBERMANN IS A SAD HAS BEEN WHO
LIVES ALONE WITH HIS CATS BUT
MET ROMNEY IS A SITTING U.S.
SENATOR.
I HO